okay
um
not the matter
my favorite cars
okay
[Music]
now
hey
oh
the appointed time having come and gone
let's uh ask our
state senators and our state
representatives to join us
today's senate majority policy committee
hearing is the second
of our hearings this year designed to
help us learn more
about the conduct of the 2020 elections
in pennsylvania
today's hearing was requested by senator
doug mastriano
who in addition to serving the 264
thousand residents
of the 33rd district in adams cumberland
franklin and york counties
also serves as the chair of the senate
governmental operations committee
as dr astriano can attest this subject
is an
excellent example not of the normal
later cake
model of intergovernmental operations
but of the marvel cake model
we have examples of local government
county government
state government and federal government
all very much involved in the design and
conduct of an election
and as we've seen not always in a
logical
rational or understandable model
i have frequently reminded the students
in the college classes which i have
taught
as well as more recently our own
governor that senators and
representatives and governors are not
kings
we're not judges we're not dictators we
are agents of public opinion
elected by the people for a fixed term
as lawmakers to provide oversight
on behalf of the public over our
government agencies
and of course as lawmakers we're here
today because we have all been receiving
massive numbers
of phone calls and emails and personal
comments when we're out bonding our dogs
in our neighborhoods
about the conduct of this election my
office has received a record number of
contacts
over 25 000 phone calls and emails
as of yesterday we all know that
pennsylvania's secretary of the
commonwealth changed the guidance
to election officials the day before the
november 3rd election
which added a completely new element of
doubt to our process
issues that should have been resolved by
the legislature
as recommended by supreme court max
justice max bearer
where it's then carried out by the
secretary without
the approval of the senator of the house
this committee held a similar event in
january of 2020
on recent changes to our state's
election laws
at that time the secretary of the
commonwealth assured us
that this process would be carried out
smoothly
the large number of complaints which we
have received from our constituents
tells us a very different story that's
why we're here today again as agents of
public opinion
senator mastrano and his staff have
assembled a number of witnesses
will share their experiences with us
regarding the conduct of this year's
election
we look forward to listening to that
testimony but before we turn there i
want to introduce
my good friend our caucus administrator
and
as of december 1st our incoming majority
leader
congratulations thank you for joining us
thank you senator arnold and thank you
senator monsterano for inviting me to
participate
and what i think is very very important
for the people of pennsylvania
as senator early said we have been
inundated with calls and emails and
messages in our social media
people are not feeling good nor
confident about the process
and the results because of that process
the president and his team
deserve this is the president of the
united states not the president of your
middle school school work so we need to
make sure that they have the room that
they need
to explore every avenue so when this is
over
we know that the process what worked in
it
what didn't work in it and what we need
to do to fix it and what we may need to
do
to address it this has been very very uh
exhausting and hard on so many in
pennsylvania
and i look forward to listening to what
the testifiers
and mr giuliani have to say to us today
so thank you very much again
and um thank you thank you master
senator
astrianna thank you kim senator
please thank you senator argo and
senator ward thank you for being here
supporting us here and welcome everybody
to the
most historic occasion in his most
historic panel
and what happened here in 1863 i think
today we're going to see it turning the
tide because we have not really heard
the truth of the arguments made on the
other side of what happened
and we're dealing with a government and
leadership in harrisburg
that wants to close their ears to what's
happened during this election and sadly
many
media that are complicit and want to
write off what happened
so for me on this battlefield in
remembering what happened 157 years ago
especially 157 years ago last week where
abraham lincoln gave his most famous
address and i think his
final sentence captures why we're here
today he said that this nation
under god shall have a new birth of
freedom
and that government other people find
the people for the people
shall not hurt the earth and everything
is at stake
and what happened
[Music]
um
you know for me
and uh
[Music]
we are out of the county named after our
second president
john adams who famously said facts are
stubborn things
let me lay out several inconvenient
truths as alberto would have us
think there have been many allegations
of voting law violations across the
state and the governor serving the
people
would have to move heaven and earth to
ensure no one was defrauded but yet he's
not moved that action
and even his secretary of state of
course says that there was no
shenanigans of great concern
and i'll remind everyone that i was a
nobody on the confirmation of kathleen
brookfire four times
that i interact with her i asked her why
are elections in afghanistan
more secure than pennsylvania and she
sat there and blinked he couldn't
devastated by conflict since 1979
what is going on here the place where
this all started in 1776 and we can't
get an election right
you got to be kidding me here and so as
a result of her inaction the governor's
inaction refusal to even look into any
of the allegations and to discount the
very essential freedoms of our citizens
we are here today to try to find out
what the heck happened in the election
you know and likewise our attorney
general our senior law enforcement
official here you know instead
of being focused on making sure things
are lined up
in kosher before one vote was counted in
pennsylvania the day before the election
declared
in the winter i mean it's there's
nothing to see here could you imagine if
the shoe was on the other foot
would the media be so gracious and
merciful and kind he was a republican
absolutely not and so houston we have a
problem here
you know one of the most troubling
things in this whole endeavor here and
it's not just because of the covet it's
just a lack of transparency and
accountability so we're here to start
shedding light on the darkness
and then of course we have a supreme
court that rewrote election law you know
act 77
but the real problem was when the
pennsylvania supreme court decided
they're going to write legislation and
rewrite our law
and because of that obviously
pennsylvania we got a lot of problems
there and that opened the door to all
the shenanigans and abuses and folly
that we're dealing with here
in the state this day
so what's going on here thousands of
people from across the commonwealth have
reached out to us
tens of thousands uh asking and
demanding action they deserve it
and as a result of the inability of our
executive branch to do their job we're
stepping in here we're co-equal members
and we're going to do our job we're
looking for transparency and truth
there's going to be no grant standing
here we're after facts and we're going
to have a good layout here what happened
you're gonna have to decide good people
of pennsylvania
on what happened and whether there's a
strong case we made or not
you know the forgotten men and women are
great feel betrayed
by their government and i'm with them i
feel the betrayal as well
so we undertake these proceedings today
to find out what happened
and then hopefully come up with an
approach where that never happens again
and the issues are galore you're going
to hear about poll watchers being denied
access
where election software vendors refuse
to testify before
the general assembly where they got to
hide
do we expect people to trust their
government and we got to earn their
trust
this is no game and the very republic
very much is at stake
and we're going to find the truth and
celebrate it you know as a soldier
and now as an elected member of the
state senate i'm not going to stand
aside and
neither
is unacceptable it's not going to happen
of the devotion and the greatest service
if we stand aside and allow bureaucrats
and corrupt politicians to steal their
voice and maybe even steal an election
we'll find out john andrew john 83
6 says that if jesus set you free
[Applause]
not only of jesus of calvary but also to
honor the sacrifice of brave men and
women in uniform and fought for and
secured our freedoms
we will be relentless in our pursuit of
the transparency of accountability and
truth
the time politics and games is over the
time of truth and justices now
in conclusion as benjamin franklin was
leading constitutional hall in 1787 he
was approached by mrs powell this is how
it went up and
why she knew that personally and she
said well mr president what do we have a
monarchy or a republic
and he says
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
to the
[Music]
district cumberland
representative county jones 93rd
district
[Applause]
representative
i'm honored to be here
[Applause]
franklin county part of
cumberland county and all of holton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
county
[Music]
[Applause]
senator mike regan from cumberland
good afternoon state representative
welcome to my
91st legislative district
[Applause]
[Music]
senator brooks and senator hutchinson
from northwestern pennsylvania senator
young from
the williamsport area senator stefano
from southwestern pennsylvania senator
laughlin
from erie senator martin from lancaster
county senator fitment from indiana
county
senator pat brown lehigh valley also
uh my my job the chairman is to remind
our panelists to keep their microphones
muted
until it is your turn to speak and also
remind everyone to strictly observe
our timeliness uh one other reminder
to our senators and witnesses at the
request of our senate attorneys
this is a legislative hearing our
purpose
is to listen to the complaints of our
constituents the oversight of government
agencies
and the need for possible legislation we
all need to conduct ourselves
accordingly with that being said uh
senator nasserano i believe you want to
introduce our first witness for 15
minutes
and we will hold to the representative
senators to understand
that we will hold all of our questions
until the conclusion of the sixth panel
i would simply say welcome to america
thank you
[Applause]
so
and all the distinguished members of the
legislature
pennsylvania we are very very honored
and very appreciative that you
are giving us an opportunity to be heard
which we've been denied
almost informally by the media
and by legislatures elsewhere
all we all we ask is if we listen to the
facts that we're
presenting and then evaluate um
we can't help with the note that we're
doing here in gaysburg
over 156 years
between uh two armies that lost over 50
and i don't want to always say it but i
do believe that those guys are
safe not only in this election
but in the way this election was
conducted and what we're going to do
about it
because if we allow elections in the
future to be conducted the way this
election was conducted
we will have false side months our
representative
during the course of this election we've
big networks big companies they only
allow one side to be heard and they
refuse to allow the other side to be
heard
it's almost as if they're afraid the
american people if they should learn
these facts
will find out just who they are and what
they're about
this uh voter fraud that took place
which as you will see from the witnesses
that recall
has several dimensions to it several
different ways in which it was done the
most
the most dangerous thing is it is very
very similar
in at least six states that we've been
able to study
in other words what we're going to
describe to you with these witnesses
happened in roughly the same way in
michigan
wisconsin nevada arizona
and georgia primary uh
device with a mail imbalance you know
there was a fierce debate over whether
we should have
mail imbalance in the first place many
scholars
many uh experts always felt that now the
ballots were very dangerous
because they're very easy to forge
at least more detroit we were warned by
justice suiter among others we will warn
by president trudy carter and former
secretary of state
james baker in a report that they did on
how to make elections more obscure
they warned us that the one thing to do
is do not go to general
mailing voting because every place
that's been used
it's like tremendous fraud and uh that
was reiterated believe it or not in an
article in new york times
in 2012 an article they have now
forgotten they wrote
uh that explained the same the same
thing
and i think what you're gonna find as
you study your mail
in mallet procedure here in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
and then in six other places
this is a terrible mistake and it
allowed
the leadership of a party that
had become pretty expert at voter fraud
to really go wild
so the
witnesses we present i'm going to first
show you
that in the case of philadelphia and in
the case of allegheny county
and one or two other counties the
mail-in ballots that were
received were not inspected
at all by any republican they were
hidden from republicans
in the case of philadelphia and
allegheny county
i can't be absolutely certain but i do
believe the witnesses
will show that a republican never got to
see
a single battle now you know how
important that is
to determining whether it is a valid
battle or not
there's only one time you get to do that
and that's when you separate
the envelope that possesses a verifying
information
from the ballot the moment you separate
them
you can no longer verify you can't go
back and recount you can't go back and
check paper ballot against
the machine mount because it's a private
ballot
it's an anonymous ballot you want to
keep it that way the only thing that
identifies it is that at our envelope
at that moment when they're separated
gone forever
that's the moment in which inspections
have been allowed
time immemorial in america pennsylvania
all over the 49 states several witnesses
here
have been doing this in 20 or 30 years
they've never heard
the situation in which the mailing
ballot was just put in
without allowing a republican a democrat
even third party members
to take one look at it and object to it
for the very reason that
it's too prone to fraud think about this
in your state republicans were
uniformly not allowed
kept out put in shoots by deal accounts
to keep them away from seeing these
ballots
never happened before not only that
the same thing was done in michigan
standing without wisconsin and on and on
and on
once shan said on the morning of
november third fourth on the start of
the camp
and at each one of those places the
democratic leadership of these
highly controlled democratic cities has
some history for corruption
in the case of philadelphia a long
history of voter fraud
i can show you the conditions i don't
think i have to
uh what are they one of the odds that
they're all going to wake up with the
same idea
if the years and years
or is it more likely that this was a
common plan
that they started with the whole idea of
having male balance
because it gives you a much wider range
to cheat
when you have just a small number of
absentee ballots like 400 000
a certain range of machine when you have
too much
2.5 million you have a much bigger range
to do that
so when you hear that testimony about
not being allowed
to see the ballot that's as much more
important
as that individual just that individual
about
on election night when i went to sleep
maybe when you did president trump was
leading
the usa by somewhere around 700 to 800
000 votes
depending on when you went to sleep
that's a huge number of votes
65 percent of the voter in the cash
under all circumstances like if this
were a fair
media your state would have called for
trump i mean virginia was called ten
percent of the vote
has turned out to be separated by one
percent
i think we may have actually won that's
another map
michigan we were ahead by 300 000 votes
wisconsin moore georgia we were down to
90
on the head
and i think there are a couple of
statistics that you have to really
closely
really closely look at i'll just mention
them and then we'll move on
to the witnesses
we have calculated and evidence will
show that there were 682
770 mailing ballots that were entered
into your votes in just allegheny county
and in philadelphia that were not
observed
by any single republican those ballots
could have all been
for joe biden they could have all been
for someone else they could have had no
identifying data they could have been
for the same person
there could have been multiples of them
there could have been no name on
we have no idea if that's true
and it will be very hard now to kind of
put them together
we could ask that you could subpoena all
of the
outer envelopes
there could have been multiples of them
there could have been no name on them
we have no idea if that's true uh
and it will be very hard now to kind of
put them together
we could ask and you could subpoena all
of the
outer envelopes it'd be very interesting
to take a look at the
682 770 outer envelopes
be very interesting if they were kept
and it'd be very interesting to see how
many of them weren't filled out but in
any event
under the law of your state which is set
by you
those ballots are illegal the judge
mistakenly in his opinion
said that we want to disenfranchise 6
million
people we don't want to disenfranchise
anyone
we want to we want to disqualify 682
000 votes so that 74 million people are
not disenfranchised
because that's that's what happened by
the cheating that went on here
i'll give you one other enormously
puzzling
statistic you sent out in the state of
commonwealth of pennsylvania 1823 148
absentee or mail-in ballots
you receive back 1.4 million
approximately
however in the count for president you
counted 2.5 million
i don't know what accounts for that 700
000 difference
between the number of ballots you sent
out and the number of ballots that ended
up in the count
that number 2 589
242 was on your government website
until yesterday and yesterday it was
removed without explanation
i'm going to be very interested in
hearing what the explanation is
and i can't imagine you could possibly
certify without knowing the explanation
of that
as well as the explanation to the 22
686 mail-in ballots that were returned
on the day they were mailed that's a
trick
how about they were returned how about
32
591 were returned
the day after they were mailed another
20 000
were returned before they were mailed
of course this is only this is i think
this is a kind of a low count
and i i guess the crooks in philadelphia
are disappointed in this
they only submitted 8021 ballots from
dead people
mail-in ballots for dead people probably
easier for dead people
to submit mail-in ballots than it is to
vote in person
you had about 30 000 of those we're
checking the records of the cemeteries
around philadelphia
you have four thousand nine hundred and
eighty four mainland ballots that were
never requested
and on and on and on and on your uh uh
your election because of these two
counties and maybe one other
is a sham it's a disgrace
to your state
and finally i i don't need to remind you
of this i think i need to remind america
of this
uh the election for the president united
states
is not run by the governor of your state
it's not run by your election
commissioner
the united states constitution makes it
clear who has the responsibility
for running this election article two
section one
cause two of our constitution
doesn't say that abc gets to call the
winner or
cnn it says
[Applause]
each state shall appoint in such manner
as the legislature thereof may direct
a number of electors it's the state
legislature that controls this
process it's your power
it's your responsibility and uh
i think you i think you know and you
have to convince the rest of your
members republican and democrat
they owe that to the people of their
state and they owe that to the people of
the united states
because if this happens without
consequence
if they can just enter six hundred
thousand some odd
mail-in ballots without allowing a
single republican
to to view it what's to say that next
time they won't do a million
or two million i know crooks really well
you give them an inch and they take a
mile and you give them a mile and they
take your whole country
so now we'll proceed with the witnesses
thank you thank you very much mr
giuliani
i've been informed that we have also
been joined on zoom by senator kristin
phillips hill
representative don kiefer representative
barb gleim from central pennsylvania
representative daryl metcalf from butler
county
and senator langerhoek from johnstown
area
senator mastrano would you like to
introduce our next
uh panel uh for the uh uh looks to me
like several people for uh 15 minutes
uh as well yes thank you thank you
senator argo
so uh our witnesses uh come first off at
jenna ellis you have any comments for
the floor or
thank you
legal legal advisor to president trump
thank you very much
and i'll reserve my comments for the end
and i would just echo
uh everything that the mayor so
eloquently stated thank you very much
thank you this is a revised list here
so we uh we'd like to call forth uh
justin
quiter from philadelphia justin are you
here okay outstanding
if you can come up to the table please
my friend and kim peterson
out of pittsburgh kim are you here come
forth please
we have a seat for you here
okay uh leah leah hopes
where are you leah please come forth
kayla could you push those two chairs
over thank you and that american flag is
mine if you said it on the table i'd
appreciate it thanks
and then uh greg stentrum from delaware
county you're zooming in i believe
oh he's here yeah of course i met you
come on over brother
okay if you can uh among yourselves
please
uh divide up the next 15 minutes and
again we'll hold all questions until the
end
please begin
i'll start
thank you senators and representatives
for inviting me to this important
hearing
my name is justin c quiter k-w-e-d-e-r
i am a resident and registered voter in
the city and county of philadelphia
i'm an attorney i am barred here in the
commonwealth
i am a volunteer certified gop canvas
observer
i was present at the philadelphia
convention center during the pre-canvas
canvas processing and counting of the
ballots cast in this year's general
election
i was first present as an observer at
the convention center and at the count
on election day
i returned as a volunteer observer to
watch the process
every day for the next 10 days i'd
approximate i was there for about 85
hours over those 10 days
part of the reason that i kept going
back was so that i could
authoritatively speak about what i saw
and again thank you for letting me be
here
because what i saw was problematic to
say the least
i can tell you that i am an eyewitness
to many
issues and irregularities that were
observed in philadelphia with the
processing and counting of the vote
i was a witness to too many issues and
irregularities to cover in a brief
opening statement
and as such i will now focus on just two
issues that i did personally observe
first the philadelphia board of
elections processed
hundreds of thousands of mail-in ballots
with zero
civilian oversight or observation the
mail-in ballots were handled processed
opened and counted in hall
f of the convention center hall f is a
vast room approximately 350 feet by 350
feet
that's about 120 000 square feet
the board of elections erected a fence
approximately 50 feet into the hall
that ran the length of the room all
observers were corralled behind the
fence
more than a hundred board workers were
pros workers processed and opened
mail-in ballots on the other side of the
fence
these masked workers were arranged
throughout the 120
000 square feet at a distance from the
observers
of about 10 feet to more than 200 feet
away from us
unlike what some may have reported in
the media the vast majority and i'd
estimate at
it at at least 96 percent of the board
workers were processing mail-in ballots
fifteen to two hundred plus
feet from us due to the distance of the
workers from the erected fences
it was impossible for me or any observer
to see what the workers were doing with
any type of specific
specificity the observers were not able
to challenge
any decision or determination being made
about the processing of these mailing
ballots
no civilian oversight over hundreds of
thousands of mail-in ballots
zero opportunity for observers to
observe challenge or inspect the
mail-ins being opened
i find this to be an issue and to be a
regular
move on to the second point the pink
highlighted duplicate ballots which i
haven't heard
about at least not in the media as the
weeks progressed the observers were
informed that the board was going to be
duplicating
damaged mail-in ballots that could not
be read by the scanners
i was told that there were more than
five thousand of these damaged ballots
i was also told that the actual number
was unknown and could be much higher
the process for duplicating these
ballots was for two workers to work as a
pair
one worker reading out loud what was
marked on the original damage ballot and
the second worker using a pink
highlighter to mark the choice on the
duplicate ballot
the board's plan then was to run the
pink highlighted ballots through the
scanners
where they would be counted as votes the
board workers did this pink highlighter
duplication work over the course of a
couple days
until thousands of ballots were
duplicated with these pink highlighters
on thursday november 12th the observers
were informed that the pink highlighter
could not be read by the scanners they
all had to be done again
all of the duplicated mail-in ballots
had to be fixed and the
philadelphia board of elections solution
to this problem was to give the workers
who were working alone
individually stacks of hundreds of what
amounted
to blank mail-in ballots and the workers
individually
were to fill in the correct highlighted
ovals with dark pen
no observation they were marking
thousands of blank million ballots
the workers did this double recreation
work for hours before the observers
realized what was going on because we
weren't told what was going on
only when the observers confronted the
deputy commissioner about this
irregularity was a system
set up where the workers would show the
observers each double recreated mail-in
ballot by flashing it at them for a
second
from a distance of six to twenty feet
away for as good as that was
thousands of million ballots were
ultimately counted
in this way again i find this to be an
issue and to be a regular
as senator masteriano recently said
elections are a fundamental principle of
our democracy
unfortunately pennsylvanians have lost
faith in the electoral system
end quote and let me add a quote that
philadelphia city commissioner of
elections al smith just made
when he said that when he said about
these recent elections
in philadelphia that these were the most
secure
and transparent elections in
philadelphia's history end quote
now i wasn't around for every election
in philadelphia's history but i can tell
you as an eyewitness
for 10 days for more than 80 hours
what i saw was not a secure and
transparent
election there are major concerns about
the legitimacy of hundreds of thousands
of ballots that were counted in
philadelphia
excuse me all right let me finish with
this
may i suggest to you that any
restoration of faith on the part of
pennsylvanians in
our electoral system can and will only
be accomplished
after an investigation into this
election
only after the law is properly applied
to this election
the idea that we can just move on by
making sure that the law is properly
applied in the next election
is in my opinion my opinion unacceptable
the issues irregularities and
illegitimacy of what i saw
leads me to conclude that the laws of
the commonwealth and of the united
states were not being followed in
philadelphia
when hundreds of thousands of ballots
were counted in this year's general
election
action must be taken now to maintain our
free and fair elections
and to preserve and protect our
election's integrity
i look forward to answering any
questions that you may have thank you
good afternoon my name is kim peterson
and i appreciate that i'm here today
thank you all for having me here today
i'm from pittsburgh pennsylvania and i
am here
to tell you what i witnessed as a
canvasser
where at the warehouse where they open
the mail and ballots
and separate them from the envelopes as
we've been discussing
as the afternoon of election day i
went to the um down to the warehouse to
be a canvasser to as a republican
representative
to be able to watch them open the
mail-in ballots and
as the gentleman justin just described
we as i was led back to the area where
we were able to view
them opening the mail-in ballots we were
kept in a corral
that was at least 15 to 20 feet from any
of the
representatives and that was the closest
people opening the ballots there were
people that were
you know 50 100 feet from us
the closest that was 20 feet about and
you could not see at all
the envelope the ballot itself where
they were stacking them anything
that was required that we were able to
be able to see
there were also monitors up around the
area the monitors were
pathetic to be honest um you they were
fuzzy looked like they were using
old technology as far as i mean we have
the most
clearest televisions created you know in
the world now
and these were you know probably from
the 60s
you're looking at all these multiple
cameras
um screenshots put together of people
opening ballots but
you could not even see at all um
or witness anything if anything was any
misdoing or anything going wrong
it was very discouraging on my part i
was very much looking forward to being a
part
of of that that day and representing
representing myself and pennsylvanians
um in a fair election and i
was um i guess discouraged about it i
love this country and i love
pennsylvania um
i was not born and raised in
pennsylvania but i have been here for
30 years and it
it is very important to me that this
election be fair
and thank you again for having me
[Applause]
first and foremost excuse me my name is
leah hoops i'm from delaware county
pennsylvania
i was a poll watcher on the day of
election
and i was also present at the counting
center in chester pennsylvania so first
and foremost thank you to this committee
and all those involved
and especially senator mastriano and
former mayor rudy giuliani
to our fearless and brave president
thank you for being our shield and
putting us first and i am forever
grateful
it is an absolute honor to be a part of
this hearing and to finally have an
opportunity to speak about what took
place in delaware county pennsylvania
i feel as an american that is my duty to
help protect the integrity of our
elections
not just for me but for every american
there are many who have lost life and
limb for my right to vote
i want to give a brief introduction in
the history of how i got involved in
this election
four years ago donald trump came down an
escalator and i knew that he was here to
take back our country
i was born and raised in delaware county
in a conservative home
i was taught from an early age to love
thy neighbor defend your country and by
all means
always speak the truth i took those
values throughout my life and applied
them in every avenue possible
which brings me up to the present and
about 18 months ago
i became a volunteer and assisted with a
campaign for a magisterial judge
in that process i was approached by my
current chairman and became an appointed
committee woman for the bethel township
republican party
in conjunction with my committee
position i also started volunteering for
the trump campaign
registering voters and assisting with
events during this time i started a
watchdog group
and reached out to the thomas more
society now associates we've been
focusing our
our efforts in election integrity our
greatest efforts have been following
closely the newly elected and completely
democrat-run
delaware county council and the democrat
majority election board
this also includes any and all
contractors support staff and any key
players involved
what we found was actually concerning
not only was private grant money used
for
from the center for tech and life owned
by google and mark zuckerberg
but pop-up voter sites were also
approved these pop-up voter sites were
placed in heavily democrat cities
including chester and upper darby
pennsylvania
in which case the grant money from the
ctcl was used to pay for electioneering
it was literally a one-stop shop walk in
apply get your ballots submit
and you were out the door but where this
didn't take place was in heavily
republican and independent areas
let's also make note that the voting
machine warehouse supervisor
is a bernie sanders delegate who is also
solely responsible for every scanner
machine card and all machines with
absolutely zero
experience
okay
okay okay sorry
um sorry i forgot where i was okay so
the real story
uh is the 2.1 million dollars spent
to move the counting center from the
courthouse in media pennsylvania which
has been something that has been done
for
for decades to the wharf in chester
pennsylvania
let me explain you the layout of the
counting center it is in the middle of a
huge parking lot which sits back on
seaport drive
next to loading docks it has
multi-million dollar connections to the
company
power hrg and subaru park soccer stadium
the accounting center was on the first
floor in which there were multiple
places
to bring in ballots in and out of
elevators and many rooms
in which workers had access i was there
for three straight days
what became of concern was the back room
which had no observers
no line of sight or transparency into
the process
there was no cooperation complete
resistance from election night and every
day after
it took until our lawyer got an
injunction to get into that back room in
which pre-canvassing was transpiring
even with an injunction which was a joke
we were granted five minutes
every two hours and the setup was
sitting in a chair
20 feet from any physical ballot i truly
wish i had enough time today to
to recreate what i witnessed and felt
during those moments but we did not
gather here today just for me and my
experience but rather a collection of
experience
experiences from americans like myself
what i hope to achieve is for the public
to understand is what we
is that we have stuck our necks out have
been intimidated
threatened bullied have spent countless
hours away from our families
friends and jobs we have signed
affidavits under penalty of perjury
which should be consideration enough to
know that this is a very serious issue
i'm here for one thing only and that is
to speak the truth
this is not about party this is about my
country
every american deserves transparency
truth and be able to question those in
power without fear of intimidation
bullying or backlash i hope this
committee takes action if needed and
justice will be swift to anyone involved
in fraudulent activity
the republic is angry disgruntled tired
beaten up and ready to defend this
country
[Applause]
thank you without election integrity we
are just another
banana republic i thank you again for
your time
efforts and service and it is an honor
to be here and to be part of a
historical moment
thank you
it's a tough group to follow my name is
gregory stenstrom
i'm from delaware county i'm a father
a family man i was a former commanding
officer and executive officer in the
navy
i'm a veteran of foreign wars i'm a ceo
of my own private company
i'm a data scientist i'm a forensic
computer scientist i'm an expert in
security and fraud
leah had recruited me for this election
and i was glad i uh thank you for that
so for the first part of the day i was a
poll watcher in the city of chester
and uh i was with just another former
u.s marine officer
and the two of us were the only gop poll
watchers
in the city of chester which is about 40
000 people
because of the consolidation for covid
there were seven polls we were allowed
you know that we were able to make it to
in 22 precincts
what we saw out there was pretty orderly
um
and uh exciting people were excited
about one of the things we saw out in
the field
was that people quite a few people had
done mail in ballots
so they came in and they hadn't been
updated in the delaware county database
yet
so they would come in and say i you know
the database is not showing me on the
database i'd like to vote
so the process uh one of the processes
was to uh
give them a uh a provisional ballot
and uh and then they would vote
provisionally and then later on their
vote would be
sorted out um that didn't happen uh i
i observed and the gentleman who was
with me observed
uh seven different polls where uh
the people were given a regular ballot
so they cast a vote and put it in
you know we let it happen a few times
you know we didn't jump all over them
you know
happened a couple of times we went up uh
in all cases the election judges were
very
forthcoming um very polite they
apologized and they said they couldn't
do it
but that somewhat spurred me to go down
to the counting center
which leah described it's on seaport ave
it's a it's a remote building
not much around it and i wanted to take
a look all day long i had been told
that there were 10 to 20 gop poll
watchers down there
and that everything was well in hand and
out of curiosity i decided to go down
i arrived at six o'clock with four other
gentlemen again foreign military and
some good citizens from from delaware
county and
we weren't allowed to get in until 11
o'clock at night and we had to get some
legal help get us so it took five hours
to get upstairs
um after that um you know what we saw
here is uh what i saw is i really think
the the the crux of this in delaware
county
is uh as an expert in this i think it's
impossible
to verify the validity of about a
hundred and hundred thousand to a
hundred and twenty thousand votes
now delaware county has got 425 000
registered voters
approximately 300 000 of them voted i
don't know what the exact number ended
up
uh mayor giuliani had nailed that number
but of that number uh over a hundred
thousand are in question
in my mind what i saw as a forensics
expert was an election process
that was forensically destructive in the
manner it was conducted
with the envelopes being separated from
the ballots and gone to the other side
of the room
the problem with that from being
forensically destructive is that when
you go to do a recount
okay the machines did a pretty good job
of recounting so if i have 120 000
ballots mail-in ballots at one side of
the room
and envelopes at the other side of the
room it's still going to come out 102
000 votes for
president vice president biden and 18
000 votes for president trump
i don't care how many times you recount
those votes you know the ballot's going
to come out the same every time
so the notion of a recount in a
forensically destructive process
is is uh doesn't work very well
um what we saw there what i saw there
was a chain of custody
in all cases that was broken it was
broken for the mail-in ballots
the dropbox ballots the election day usb
card flash drives
in all cases the chain of custody
and the procedures that were defined by
the delaware county board of elections
and election process review were all
they didn't follow one
i i couldn't even redline this
multi-page document because the entire
document
would be they didn't follow any of the
procedures
so i personally observed usb v cards
being uploaded to the voting machines by
the
the voting machine warehouse supervisor
on multiple occasions
i saw this personally i brought it to
the attention of the
deputy sheriff who was there stationed
who was a senior law enforcement officer
and i brought it to the attention of the
clerk of elections
i brought it to their attention i
objected and i said
this person is not being observed he's
not part of the process that i can see
and he's walking in with baggies which
we have pictures of and that was
submitted to in our affidavits
and he was sticking these usbs into the
machines so i personally witnessed over
that that happened
24 times over 24 times
we have multiple other witnesses to
start including democrat poll watchers
and we were told um i was told the next
day
uh by uh the uh
solicitors uh well actually not the
solicitor but the attorney that we had
secured that they said every election
they leave a couple of usbs
in the voting machines and they're
brought back and generally the warehouse
manager comes over and puts them in
so in talking to the u.s attorney
general
mcswain and other law enforcement
officers
i found out that was not the case that
generally uh you know
more than more than two is unusual
so they denied they did it but
as of today 47 uspv cards are missing
and they're nowhere to be found so i was
told personally
that these 32 these 24 to 30 cards that
were uploaded
weren't there those cards uh i demanded
that the uh they didn't update the vote
live time they only updated it about
once every two or three hours
i demanded they updated the vote so i
could see what the the uh
what the what what the result was and it
was uh
50 000 votes
and i think as a computer scientist an
american and a patriot
it doesn't matter who those 50 000 votes
were
i'll tell you for vice president biden
but
what was shocking to me as an american
as someone who has uh gone to sea gone
to war
that um that could even happen
so several other things that uh came up
was
on thursday it took us three days for
them to obey the court order
that i secured with leah's help and the
help of the thomas more society
who we thank uh incredibly uh good
patriots
they they got us in there uh they got
the order for us
to get in and watched it uh look at the
back offices which were locked
uh for five minutes every two hours i
went in i was the first one allowed to
go in
at 1 30 on thursday and then again at 3
30 for five minutes
the county solicitor had a stopwatch on
the first time i was not allowed to
touch anything the second time i did
what i observed in the locked room in
the back office
was seventy thousand unopened mail-in
ballots
they were in boxes of five hundred
stacked in
neatly the gentleman that came in with
me
is a was a dem uh democrat poll watcher
is a forensic pathologist a very
detailed
very dedicated man and he took
meticulous notes as well
and i verified with him are you seeing
what i'm seeing
we both agreed as gop poll watchers and
a democrat poll watcher
that we had uh witnessed 70 60 to 70
000. we had a little bit of a
disagreement there
the problem with that was by that time
the mail-in ballots had already been
counted
so 120 000 mail-in ballots had already
been counted posted
and done so my question is
where do the seventy thousand ballots go
and nobody knows we have a picture in
here
of a large number of boxes that i took
that were filled with what appeared to
be ballots
sitting by the blue crest machine they
were there for about three hours and
then they disappeared
i found it notable when i watched it the
first one they were taking the ballots
up and down
i said i am an expert in fraud i saw the
ballots
going up multiple elevators and iraq's
and i think a lot of well-meaning people
and a lot of honest people were there
doing that they were trying to
participate in the process
and i would say that uh 99 of the people
there
um the way the process was designed i
believe
that people thought it was a
non-fraudulent process
i heard that said many times i was uh
you know i said there's no fraud going
on here i said well i'm not you know i
didn't even bring that up but i think
people
saw what they wanted to see and they saw
what was intended for them to see
i called it at one point kabuki theater
i said it was all designed for us to
see it it was entertaining there were
cameras on it when we finally got into
the back room where the votes were being
ingested as a data scientist i want to
see where where the data's coming in
and i wanted to know the universe of the
votes well the universe of the votes was
only supposed to be 120
000 mail in ballots we were told there
were six thousand ballots remaining
so i said okay we have a universe of 126
000 votes
and then when i get back there the
universe wasn't 126 000 votes the
universe was 200 000 votes
so that's a problem i think the last
thing i wanted a couple of other things
is the blue crest sorter machine uh was
only manned by one person
you know people ask me all the time how
do people commit crimes
um i know there's a lot of theories here
and i always look for the simplest thing
people that stuff that you know sticking
usb sticks in
putting ballots in very simple thing
only takes a couple of people
doesn't take a big conspiracy i think
people look at things and they use
inflammatory words
and you know like fraud and so forth as
a forensic computer scientist
my interest is in the data where did it
go
where did the spoilage go how did the
data come in
and go out of the system so i think as a
scientist we need to look at that we
need to audit that
what was really upsetting to me and the
most upsetting was i had
spoken to multiple law enforcement
agencies and
literally begged multiple law
enforcement agencies to say go in
and it's in order to prove you know
prove that nothing's happening
you neither exonerate yourselves in the
process or refute what i'm saying
please it's very simple process
just go get the forensic evidence from
the computers
it's a simple process you take the dot
you turn the computer off
it's non-destructive takes moments maybe
half an hour
20 minutes to do it properly and collect
the evidence
you open the computer up you take a a
device called a bit blocker
you put it in the hard drive it's done
under the observation of law enforcement
officers
they take a forensic image of the drive
put it all back together
it wouldn't have taken more than an hour
to to image all five machines
that was never done
despite my objections and that was three
weeks ago
lastly when they said they said well
we've got all the forensic records and
so forth
we just learned two days ago that
virtually
all chain of custody logs records
yellow sheets everything
was gone all forensic
evidence all custody seats in delaware
county
are gone they had a signing party where
they sat down
and and poll workers were invited back
to recreate those logs
and our understanding as of today was
that they were unsuccessful in getting
them all
so we have a situation where we have
a hundred thousand ballots to 120 000
ballots both mailing and usb
they're in question now there's no cure
for this there's no remedy for this
as a home is a home charter we can we
could have a re-election in delaware
county for our own representatives
within our own town but there is no cure
for that for the president of the united
states
and i don't believe as a citizen and an
observer to this
that anybody could certify that vote
in any good conscience and if the
democrats that
were part of this process you know were
so you know
had done things follow their own
procedures which they created almost
unilaterally
we would be in a situation where they
could exonerate themselves
and they could say mr stenstrom you've
been misinformed
we have evidence here that refutes what
you say
but that's not the case they can't do
that so i say if you can't certify that
vote
and you can't certify a hundred thousand
votes out of three hundred thousand
you can't certify delaware county and
i'm done and thank you for your time and
patience
thank you all to this panel
before i have senator mastriano
introduce the next 15-minute panel
i want to note that we've also been
joined on zoom by representative kathy
rapp
from northwestern pennsylvania doug
thank you panelists
if you can stay in the area we're gonna
bring up the next group here we're gonna
save questions and answers before the
end
uh mr mayor i understand my my list
might not be synchronized i'm gonna ask
you to
introduce the next folks coming up to
testify
if you could pass the mic to the mayor
somebody
thank you all
we could call up for four more witnesses
like this
or we could now put on the statistical
expert
who could explain some of this and then
put on the additional
either way you prefer okay then we'll
call colonel waldron
and if you don't mind if i can interrupt
and ask him a few questions
i can probably get it directed it's good
for me to do that because i don't
understand it so
i'm only kidding colonel please
introduce yourself good afternoon
senator uh
colonel and gentlemen ladies
my name is phil waldron i'm a retired
army co-owner 30 years
i spent the first half of my career just
like colonel mostriano here as a
cavalry officer conducting armed
reconnaissance counter reconnaissance
last half of my career spent in
information warfare
as a psychological operations officer
and information operations officer
conducted computer network operations
electronic warfare special electronic
warfare
deception counter deception and opsec
and a couple other specialties
sir you still got stets in his purse
uh so i spent most of my all of my time
as an operations officer
my perspective looking at this uh
this problem set is how to break in how
to break it how to destroy it how to
manipulate it
and um my team has been researching this
specific issue since
august but we're working with another
team that's been
intently working on this problem set the
voting machine manipulation for two
years
since the ted cruz and beto race in
texas in 2018
and the kentucky governor's race where
there were significant anomalies
observed and i like to add that there
are many many more teams
like ours small small teams that are
joined in this fight
and they're throwing the flag left and
right so
there's a lot of folks that are
recognizing anomalies
the voting systems in the u.s and in
pennsylvania were built to be
manipulated
they've been used in elections around
the world um in stolen elections
around the world in venezuela italy
argentina singapore bolivia as close as
two weeks ago the philadelphia uses esns
pittsburgh uses dominion other counties
in
pennsylvania use dominion and other
systems
so what's uh what's the real deal
so all of these election systems have a
common dna
uh sgo smartmatic um sold sequoia voting
systems to dominion in 2010
and then the diebold uh company spun off
premier election systems
dominion as a result of an anti-trust
suit
so the bottom line is that these systems
have similar code
and similar functions um and just so you
know i know there have been statements
to the contrary but i personally
debriefed the son of a cuban
intelligence officer
who had first-hand knowledge of hugo
chavez's family members who told him
not to worry about the populist threat
against maduro's election in venezuela
quote unquote that it was guaranteed
their father invested the money to build
the sgo
voting machine system so i have no
reason to doubt this gentleman he's uh
sworn in affidavit to this effect uh but
uh that's that's the root of the uh the
sgo
voting machines so these systems are not
what you've been told
they are connected to the internet and
servers outside of the us they're
connected from top to the bottom in the
middle
there is no transparency as as our
previous witnesses mentioned as to how
the voter information is processed
how and where it's stored the voting
record is able to be modified and or
deleted by operators administrators and
outside
threats operators can assign votes for
write-in
ballots blank ballots or error ballots
in large numbers so that they can be
directed toward one candidate
or another at the operators or
supervisors discretion
and many experts have published uh how
easily these machines can be hacked
to manipulate votes as a matter of fact
one of our white hat hackers
previously discovered a malware that's
present on the servers
that captures every login and every
password of every
operator down to the precinct level that
logs into one of these systems
that's just like giving your the
password to your bank account out uh
putting it on the dark web it's not
going to be there very long
and just so you probably are all aware
on 30 september
an election storage facility was robbed
in your state 30 usb devices were stolen
and a laptop
those those usb devices more than likely
had
encryption devices and you've just heard
another previous witness
talk about the the the non-standard use
of
of the usb storage devices so these
systems
uh in a nutshell allow authorized and
unauthorized users to cancel votes
shift votes preload votes vote blank
ballots
all in real time and in large numbers
they're connected from a top to the
bottom
so one bad actor or a team of bad actors
can have equally negative inputs
it's been described uh by a uh
another uh person in another state that
we're working with
just like the lotto whoever whoever
organizes the lotto is always going to
win
it's controlling the numbers and it's
controlling the margins
our experts and other academics believe
that up to 1.2 million pennsylvania
votes could have been altered or
fraudulent
this is what we discovered in the last
22 days
really only a detailed forensic analysis
of the actual machines and software will
truly show how many pennsylvania
citizens
have had their civil rights violated
so to use these type of machines with
little or no audit trails
little or no transparency of how the
votes are processed
where they go where they're stored will
never leave the public satisfied that we
truly have
a representative democracy
uh i'd like to correct something the
mayor said i am not a statistician
i'm a combat officer and i didn't do
well in math
but i i can understand the numbers that
he put out earlier
um i want to want to share with you one
chart i believe it's in your
in your package so what our team has
has done is focused on the spike
anomalies
and these are events where a numerical
amount of votes are processed in a time
period that's not
feasible or mechanically possible under
normal circumstances
i believe that uh greg stenstrom
mentioned earlier
the processing of these ballots through
machines
there's a manufacturer's specified rate
of speed that a number of ballots
can image be imaged and processed
those these spike anomalies in this
chart
really show where where for us to look
forensically to actually determine
what happened with these votes um
our team has is looked at at these
systems
and there are a dozen ways to to
interdict the voting process
uh in the issue whether whether it's
mail-in ballot manipulations
they can scan and allocate boats uh
blank votes
uh where there was a 70 000 votes left
in the back room
there's there's just lots of ways to
interdict these uh
these systems so with that
i'll uh answer any potential questions
thank you next panel please
yes sir ask him to clarify one or two
things
when we look at this pennsylvania fixing
the vote
chart that they all have could you
explain
at the very beginning what that line
means biden injection so at the very
very beginning of the chart where
there's a circle it says on election day
what that indicates is there is a spike
in
loaded votes 337 000
plus or minus some votes that were added
in there
in one big batch so that was an anomaly
in the reporting normally you would
expect to see a smooth curve
going up not any uh not any big
big spikes that's kind of what what greg
was talking about the
the anomalies of loading and uploading
those uh those votes so that big spike
that uh occurs there is a prime
indicator of
fraudulent voting and that's 604 000
votes
in 90 minutes is that right correct this
is
uh 337 votes
337 000 votes in that uh
in that period of time yes and when you
look at this entire curve
with all these spikes can you calculate
how how much of a vote that accounted
for for biden
and how much for trump close to six
hundred thousand i think our
our figures are about 570 some odd
thousand that uh
all those spikes represented over time
for by correct
and how much for trump i think it was a
little over 3200. now
just just to go back to your original
your original document this one pager
that they all have
mail-in ballots counted without being
observed
those are the ballots we were talking
about that were not observed in
allegheny county
and in and in philadelphia correct is
that right
682 770. now this is the part
that is a mystery mailed ballot sent
out one million eight hundred and twenty
three thousand one hundred and forty
eight
but when you go to the count of the
final count of the vote
there are 2 589 242
mail-in ballots what what happened
how do how do you account for the 700
000
mail-in ballots that appeared from
nowhere
so our our uh
cyber team uses white hat hacking
techniques they gathered a lot of public
publicly available information and that
information was from the secretary of
state's website
that website has been updated
as late as 11 16 this morning with
provisional and mail-in ballots so those
numbers are still changing
they changed last night so it's a
continual target this is 22 days after
the election
that that number the two point um
the 2.5 million number is uh is no
longer on the website
just been taken off it's not there is
there any explanation for why it's been
taken off there's no annotations
but the um has there been a change made
in the
2 million 589 242
mail-in votes that have been countered
in the total vote i'd have to check
the secretary of state's website as a
could you also check and see
have is there any change in the 1823
1448 ballots that was sent
out the mail out ballots number seems to
be holding steady
and was there any other method
of producing ballots out other than
sending them out
not that we're aware of unless as
previous uh
witnesses of testimony that the
potential for multiple
ballot counts so the ballots could have
been have you ever gotten a chance to
examine any of these ballots
no that's uh that would be part of the
forensic
process one suggestion whoever
does the analysis is uh using paper and
ink analysis of the a micro
photo spectrometer that would analyze
the
the ink on those ballots to see if they
were mass produced
so in addition to the 682 770 ballots
that were entered without a single
inspection of any kind
there also appear to be something like
700 000 ballots mail-in ballots
that were never sent out that were
counted there there are no
discrepancies in the in the secretary
pretty big discrepancies
yes sir and that's been there thank you
we do have to press on to the next panel
since we have a lot of questions about
attending here
mr america could you introduce the next
panelist so now we have um
jane winters
gary feldman who's going to be on a zoom
is he here well then have him come up
please
please come up as you call i believe
charles
nudo and udo
and david chestakas
i think i have them all i think
thank you gentlemen we'll start with the
men physically in the room here with
your testimony
and then go to the zoom after that so
please thank you senator
my name is gary feldman i am a resident
and voter
and of philadelphia city and county i'm
registered as a republican
i have been involved with foot off of
republican politics for over 20 years
now
i've had watcher certificates
and on this past november third
uh 2000 2020 i was issued a watcher
certificate
to be the watcher for president donald
trump
this is the walkthrough certificate that
i was given
and it is issued for
president donald trump to me um
these watcher certificates um i'm not
sure the exact year i'm going to say
about 2002 or 2003
are now for county-wide so everywhere in
the county the watchers certificate
is good for so it's put off yet is city
and county so this watch
certificate which reads this this
certificate
authorized the individual to watch in
any water division
in philadelphia and that's what the
the like the top line if you want to see
the watch certificate
gladly bring it up so anyway
uh i was in my vehicle uh
as uh kind of like
volunteering for the president with a uh
an attorney
and we were he was monitoring any kind
of uh
problems that could happen in
philadelphia he uh his name was will
chamberlain and he was pretty good on
twitter and other social media stuff
so we got a word that they were not
letting
republican watchers in the polling
places
in south philly so we went to a place
uh which happened to be a funeral parlor
where they were doing the election
and uh i walked in with the watchers
certificate
in both hands to make sure that they
wouldn't snag it out of my hand
they immediately identif wanted me to
identify myself
one of the problems that happens is the
republican watcher certificates are
this gold orange color
where the democrats are like a light
blue
i don't i've never really seen one but i
heard they're light blue so they know
right away that we're republicans coming
in there to watch
so uh two uh what
two poll workers i don't know who they
were they were wearing masks and
everything
um i produced a certificate and she
starts saying it's not good here
uh and i'm like it is and i said please
read the top line
the gentleman that was with her uh said
would you like to go outside and talk
about this
um you know i was not looking for a
confrontation i
the other thing is too is i did have my
uh
bandana on they had their face shield
but they weren't practicing fake
social distancing they were right on top
of me
so we did step outside because she
wanted to step
outside will chamberlain
is not a philadelphia resident so he's
not issued a philadelphia washer
certificate
and he proceeded to take a video of me
having a confrontation on the street
with these two
um i don't know who they were
i don't know they were poll workers you
know they never identified who they were
and uh the video
uh which was released to the public is a
little over 30 seconds on twitter
and it already has 3.8 million hits
on wha will will's uh
twitter page uh there is a complete
video it's on my phone and i know i did
give it made it available to the
senators it's over a minute
about what happened on the street um i
tried to
explain this watchers certificate is for
the city of philadelphia
you're in the city of philadelphia and
you have to let me observe
i'm the eyes and ears of the president
of the united states and they wouldn't
allow that
thank you for the opportunity to be
excuse me be here today oh sir yeah
i just want to i just want to add
another thing that it's really kind of
crucial
uh when this happened the fact checkers
uh group organization
you know what they are started to put
disclaimers
on my the video um fact tracker said
they contacted me
fact checkers never contacted me fact
checkers said that it was a
misunderstanding
they said the commissioner's office
tried contacting me
they used the name kevin feely from the
commissioner's office i don't know who
kevin feely is nobody from the
nobody from fact checkers called me i
don't know if they have my phone number
and the commissioner's office did
nothing
to follow up on any of this i did see
commissioner al schmidt
when we were doing the canvassing but we
didn't mention anything about what
happened that day
good afternoon i'm dave shastokis i'm an
attorney
a licensed practice law in illinois in
florida
some time ago i was a cook county
assistant state's attorney prosecutor
during that time i actually did election
law enforcement during the course of
that time including um
seeing two that people had appropriate
access and precinct openings and
closings that machines were zeroed out
since that time i've either been a
candidate or a campaign in over
10 other 10 other individual elections
and in
2016 i actually worked for as a
volunteer for
the trump rubio campaign in broward
county florida
i discovered them opening mail-in
ballots in a
locked room before that was all said and
done we actually had a broward county
judge
monitoring everybody's access he was
actually on-site monitoring everybody's
access to
see to it that that could happen issue
to it that everybody would have
appropriate access
currently i am lead counsel
in conjunction with judicial watch in a
suit called the
illinois conservative union versus the
illinois state board of elections
for violations of the board in terms of
the national voter registration act
i given that kind of background to give
you some idea of where i'm coming from
on
on this subject on october 24th
this year i came to pittsburgh as a
volunteer with lawyers for trump and i
was
asked to organize folks to do monitoring
of the pre-canvas
pre-canvas activities during the course
of the next week about
myself with some other volunteers made
over 500 phone calls we recruited 50
individuals that were willing to come in
canvas
or come and monitor the pre-canvas and
along
with 25 other out-of-state lawyer
volunteers
we had organized all this because of
course we had 19
in in the in allegheny county there were
19 republicans on the ballot
and so we were able to have credentials
through the rcac
uh for uh 19 watchers at any given
moment
so we had to organize them so we
organized everybody during the course of
time and they had given us credentials
in advance and then two days
before the election on
well the friday before the election we
got a call from the electoral board and
said
oh by the way you need to submit
everybody's credentials in advance
and you need to have everybody's
signatures on the credentials that you
sign in advance
and uh of course we'd already had put
together a team of 70 and we'd allocated
them four hours uh
four hours of time over in four hour
shifts to be able to monitor
through the course of the whole period
of time and then over the next three
days we scrambled like heck to
try and get uh signatures uh
from the various volunteers and
other other council that were assisting
us needless to say we
lost about 20 25 uh folks that we were
unable to get the credentials to in
advance
uh and get the signatures back and forth
and
all the things necessary to do that so i
just i
wanted to mention that you're hearing
about a global huge global issues but
it goes down to the petty as well it
goes down to the petty as well in terms
of
interfering with his
uh his his access and interfering with
changing rules i know secretary
bookfar changed some huge rules but the
local boards
day in and day out were changing rules
as well to make make the monitoring
process
next to uh next to impossible
at any rate we we did that and
then we wound up i went with a group
at about 6 45 on election day to 901
pennsylvania avenue in
allegheny allegheny county where they
were doing the
pre-canvas and at the at the time when
when we arrived we were herded into
what best known as the corral i'm sure
you've kind of
seen or heard about those things it was
a fenced in area that was about the
fence was maybe
two and a half three feet high um
closest uh
anybody could get would do any uh
make any observations was maybe 15 20
feet from the closest
closest ballot processor to the maybe
150
feet because we're in about a 20 000
square foot area where the
biggest room was taking place uh biggest
activity was taking place but i would
mention that the mail-in ballots were
coming into that room
already sliced open at the top
we have no idea when or where the
slicing took place
where the opening took place or what was
in fact in inside those ballots
inside those mailing envelopes at that
point in time folks were
then separating the mail-in ballot from
the
secrecy envelope you could see that you
know that's exactly what they're doing
they put one on the side and one on the
other side
and then then they take them and put
them
put them someplace and i have no idea
and then the secrecy
envelopes would go to another slicing
machine and that be sliced open
and at that point then the balance would
come back and they'd be
divided from the secrecy envelopes we
had really no
no concept of what was going on in the
room next door there was a smaller room
around
around the corner that you had to leave
the 20 000 square foot room there was
one
about 7 500 square feet and in that room
there was a there was a machine the
machine would be
apparently sorting sorting things by by
the barcodes
and then eventually somehow or other
people would come in with
big arm loads of ballots from the from
the other room
apparently with no providence no uh no
explanation of where they came from
and uh here's uh here's an interesting
uh thing that uh
um you guys might consider when uh when
you're
doing this in the future uh the biggest
one of the biggest bottlenecks
uh would take place at this point in
time because all these belts came in
folded tri-folded right and all the
ballots had to be
flattened and so they would take the
ballots and put them under big stacks of
reams and reams of paper to flatten them
out and then there'd be workers
needing the ballots to try and make them
so that they could
go through the machines and when
everybody's saying well you haven't
counted anything for uh you know x
number hours and they said well we're
trying to flatten the ballots
um yeah no it just it was it was absurd
and obscene
uh so at any rate uh that was that and
when everybody was waiting
that's what was going on they're
flattening they're flattening the
balance for for most part
and then then there was about six
machines where they were feeding the
ballots
and while they would had six machines uh
feeding the balance
as they would go in two or three would
kick out to a different trade than than
the other
tray and workers sometimes would take
the ones that weren't kicked out and put
them in a
put them in a stack and then sometimes
you'd run all of them through again and
sometimes run
two or three we never had any idea if
they were zeroing out a machine
what they were doing i asked i asked the
solicitor the county solicitor who was
there i said what's uh what's going on
he told me that this was a pitney bose
representative working there that had
been sworn in as a county
uh representative and uh that uh
sometimes
um the ballot machine doesn't doesn't
count those
things and then so he runs them through
and but there was absolutely no
providence to what uh what was going on
in the counting machines
i have no idea because of course they
would just uh take stacks of
take stacks of ballots that had been
sitting under uh reams of paper trying
to be flattened and then
run them through the machine so we have
no idea about that
and so at one point i asked the county
solicitor
i said um can you describe for me
the journey of a ballot from the time it
hits the door
to the time that it's counted what where
does it go what's the process etc
i had a short answer no
i then asked him i said
can you give me any written protocol
about what is supposed to happen it hits
the door
then it then it goes to a machine
theoretically sorted by barcodes from
what i understood from someone else
so that if there's a challenge in
advance of the election they know where
to
they know where to look because of
course at 5 pm on the
friday before elections you can
challenge things for people having
died and a few other reasons
and but then i say i asked i said is
there any written protocol for that
and he said no we have no written
protocol
for uh what we're what we're conducting
uh what we're doing here
so uh he answered um he's supposed to be
the one giving legal advice to people on
how to legally handle ballots
and he tells me that he doesn't know how
they're handled and he tells me that
there is no written protocol on how they
are supposed to be handled
so i might suggest uh that
there was just add literally no way to
no way to change
i mean there was no way to challenge
there was no way to look at those
ballots and i would say
in my experience electoral experience
one of the
one of the things that legitimizes
elections is the ability
of an not a disinterested third party to
to review what the process is but
actually an adversarial third party to
review what the what the process is
and this was completely and utterly
absent
i had about 20
25 other affidavits from other folks
that had joined me during the
during the time that have been part of
this that describe essentially the same
thing
over there in allegheny county most of
whom were
most of whom were attorneys and have
been versed on the
comings and goings of the pennsylvania
supreme court
which i might suggest
ultimately the last decision in ray
canvassing
when the pennsylvania supreme court
ultimately said
that it doesn't matter how far you're
away from the ballots because
you don't have the right to challenge
anything anyway
i read the opinion and i said to myself
the pennsylvania supreme court just
called off elections
in the state of pennsylvania and i
would suggest that the remedy for what
the pennsylvania supreme court does
lies with the distinguished legislators
that are
before me but the fact is is if there is
no
there is no opportunity for anybody to
look at them
and and the court has the temerity to
say
you it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if you come in or not
it doesn't matter how far you are
because even if you're there you don't
have any right to do anything sure
um if you could summarize sir we are
running yes i'm sorry
i'm sorry uh i apologize for being an
attorney
no i i apologize senator but i just
um one yeah i'll summarize in one thing
one of the guarantees in the united
states constitution
is that in fact every state shall have a
republican form of government
and i would suggest to i would suggest
to you if the supreme court of
pennsylvania determines that they're
going to run the state
and allow the local election authorities
to essentially appoint winners
the state of pennsylvania no matter no
longer meets that guarantee
as a republican former government thank
you thank you sir
[Applause]
if we could go to our two witnesses on
zoom now you can come forth
and go ahead and start when you're ready
hi my name is elizabeth priet heavy i am
an attorney
and a resident of montgomery county and
the chair of the montgomery county
republican committee
thank you senators and mayor giuliani
for providing me the opportunity to
speak
after the primary our committee prepared
and provided to the pa legislative
leaders
and members of the montgomery county
staff in charge of the election
a 30-page report of the mail-in ballot
and election day problems and
irregularities we experienced
in montgomery county we made detailed
recommendations for changes with the
hope that the general election would be
smoother
unfortunately that was not the case
there are a number of issues that
evidence a total lack of transparency
regarding the handling
of the general election in montgomery
county first
the montgomery county republican
committee was not provided
meaningful view of the mail-in ballots
at any time despite our requests
second we were not provided with regular
detailed information about the mail-in
ballots over the course of the election
despite our requests
third we still lack complete and
detailed information
about these ballots despite our requests
we were provided our first opportunity
to view learn about the canvassing site
on
sunday november 1st just two days prior
to the election
at that visit the chief operating
officer of the county
showed us the room where the canvas was
to take place
to our shock we were told we could not
directly
check the mail and ballots after some
significant pushback by me
the county agreed to allow two watchers
inside the
room but they were never able to see the
ballots up close
again there was no meaningful
observation of the ballots
and absolutely no check of the ballots
by anyone
other than the county staff which is all
run by the democrats
as to whether or not these ballots met
election code criteria
at the most basic level we were not even
able to check to see if a vote
twice or if a voter was deceased
and with the removal of the signature
being a check for existing voters there
was no way to protect against someone
fraudulently voting for a registered
voter
in addition to having no meaningful
observation or review of over
two hundred thousand mail and ballots we
were not provided with the change in
rules by the county
to allow the curing of mail-in ballots
in a timely manner
on thursday october 29th i received an
email from frank dean who ran the
election for the county with a list of
ballots
with what they described as defects and
if the voter had been contacted by the
county to cure
the defect at the tour of the county the
canvas on november 1
we were shown bundled mail-in ballots
divided by precinct
which the county identified as having a
defect and explained that those
individuals had not cured these ballots
as of november 1st
the county did not provide the
montgomery county republican committee
with an opportunity to have an
authorized representative
present in what was effectively the
pre-canvas
illegal term pre-canvas of the ballots
when it reviewed and contacted voters
about their defective mail and ballots
after immediate investigation it was
clear that other counties across
pennsylvania
were not allowing this illegal
pre-canvassing to take place
in particular our neighboring county
berks county
county that the president won by over 8
percent interpreted the law as written
and did not contact voters to cure
balance weeks prior to the election as
montgomery county did
a portion of berks county and most of
montgomery county share one
congressional seat
so voters were not treated equally in
these two counties in the same district
since the election we have received many
calls and emails from
republicans with questions about whether
their mail-in ballot was counted
expressing concerns that they didn't
request a mail on ballot but received
one anyway
that they were made to go provisional
when they shouldn't have
that they have great concerns about the
efficacy of this election
there is a real disenfranchisement of
voters across
montgomery county many people feel
their vote did not count because we
lack the information we need to tell
them otherwise
and because we were not able to have any
meaningful check on mail-in ballots
we cannot provide these concerned voters
with the assurance they need
that the process was fair and that the
election was honest
in addition to the lack of transparency
we experienced in montgomery county
the kathy barnett for congress campaign
found with just the minimal information
that we've
been able to obtain that at least 188
deceased people in montgomery county
voted
in 2020 they also found
concerning anomalies in the results for
example
more people voted in the small town of
norristown for the very first time
than the voters who vote regularly
this occurrence is far outside the norm
of what we have seen
in past elections these numbers must be
reviewed
and analyzed in fact a full review of
the mail-in ballots across the state
must be done
in order for this country to have trust
in the electoral process
elections must be viewed as open and
transparent both the democrats and the
republicans should be provided with the
same information throughout the process
and there should be meaningful
opportunity to observe and object
not last-minute disclosures and rule
changes
this legislature must reform the
election law to provide for such
transparency all along the mail and
ballot process
from start to finish and people need to
feel confident that the same rules apply
to each and every voter in every town
and in every county in this state
thank you
okay uh next member on the zoom are you
are you up thank you
do we have contact
she's still on okay there you are we're
ready please proceed
we're julie thank you oh
she's going go ahead um hello thank you
for having me here today
my name is julie behe and i'm a resident
of montgomery county and the executive
director of the montgomery county
republican committee
i'm here to speak with you today
regarding my experience as an
observer of the pre-canvas and canvas of
the mail and ballots
in montgomery county we had over 250 000
mail-in ballots requested for the
general election
in the weeks leading up to the election
i personally trained over 100 volunteers
to inspect
and monitor the counting of these
ballots to ensure the legitimacy of the
vote in montgomery county
unfortunately they were never given this
opportunity
on sunday november 1st during a
walk-through of the mail and ballot
facility
we learned that no watchers were
permitted to inspect or even see the
outside envelope of the ballot
after some significant pushback by our
chairman liz heavy the accounting agreed
to
allow two watchers inside the room of
which i was one
as an observer at the canvas i was
corralled into a small
narrow holding area which is blocked off
by tables plexiglas barriers
in the corner of the room due to the
room layout and location of the holding
area within the room
i only had visibility to the space where
ballots were flattened and scanned
this was a huge area and the closest
scanner was roughly six feet away and
the farthest approximately 25 yards away
from my position within the holding area
i had no visibility or access to the
room
where balls were sorted outside
envelopes were inspected and both
outside and secrecy envelopes were open
this space was divided from the scanning
room by a large white wall
blocking all visibility to the slicing
machines the blue crest sorter
and the ballot storage room in my
opinion this was a totally separate room
and not one room as the county election
board argued
during our walk through of the campus
facility on sunday november 1st
we argued that this was a separate room
and was told by the county chief
operating officer
that we would be able to view this space
by security camera footage
the footage from these cameras was
streamed to televisions in a conference
room on the other end of the building
which was approximately a four minute
walk away from where the ballot canvas
room was
the system was not set up on our walk
through day and it was not until i
arrived
back at the facility on 7 am on election
day that i could see the footage was
extremely poor quality
and you could only see pixelated images
of workers moving around the room and
had no meaningful visibility of the
ballots over the last 10 months
in my role i have spoken to thousands of
voters firsthand who have lost faith in
the election processes
and procedures in montgomery county and
across pennsylvania as a whole
today i still lack the information
needed to properly inform voters that
their vote was in fact counted
i thank you for holding these hearings
today and a hope that the appropriate
legislative changes are made
to restore confidence in our elections
thank you
thank you
facts are stubborn things and i
appreciate you guys laying it out there
it doesn't make a difference mayor if
you can introduce the final panelists
before we go to question and answer time
i believe there are two
other two more on zoom okay please come
forth uh friends on zoom when you're
ready
here we are
we're here but we can't see ourselves
can you hear us we hear you loud and
clear please begin
okay uh my name is charles noodle i live
in drums pennsylvania can you
hear me yes
can you see me on the screen you're not
on the screen
no but please continue
okay go ahead my mother no we got
somebody else
my name is barbara salika i went to the
voting polls on november the 3rd to vote
in person
i waited two hours in line and when i
went
in i showed identification and i was
taken
up to the polling place
this polling man
showed me what to do turned it on and
said go ahead
i voted and i printed it out
and when i got it and i looked at it
trump was not
on there i voted for trump and it wasn't
there
my daughter i called her over and i said
to her
look his boat is gone i voted for him
so i called a poster over
and he said it's not supposed to be seen
it's for privacy just put it through the
scanner and you're done
it bothered me it's been bothering me
since
because i voted and was it counted
or was it flipped i don't know
and i'm speaking on my mom's behalf also
as a witness my name is cheryl noodle
i was there that day i drove her to the
polls
when she got done voting she showed me
the printout
and she was saying how the president's
name that she voted for was not printed
out when all the other
delegates that she had voted for were on
the printout
me not knowing because i had not voted
yet how the printout was supposed to
look
we went to the pollster that was there
and asked him
why the president and vice president's
name did not
print out when all the other names of
the candidates printed out that my
mother had voted
for it seemed very strange
um but not knowing any better we asked
well what is the next step
and he said oh i'm sorry he said that um
it did not print out because that's uh
for voters privacy
that none of them vote but none of them
print out so we asked him what the next
step was and he said to put it through
the scanner so that's what we did and we
left and it seemed very odd
then i went to where i live in drums
pennsylvania which is about
10 miles uh south of where my mother
voted
and um i voted no problem everything
printed out just as
um you know it should and i scanned it
through
so it just seemed very odd and we wanted
to report that that
in my mother's area which was fairview
township
it seemed very odd that it did not print
out
thank you
okay i'm charles nudo and uh
by the way my mother-in-law is 84 years
old
she forgot to mention that anyway my
wife
then i'm sorry she's 80.
my my wife called me that day and she
was distraught
and told me everything they just called
you
so i go to my polling place around 3 30
4 o'clock here in drums
and when i first walked in a young
gentleman came up to me start explaining
how to vote
and he said take this stylus
make your choices then print it out with
a printer that's underneath the machine
and i thought that's odd i've been
voting since 1992.
we never had a print a ballot and i
actually thought
it was easier to vote in 92 on the world
war
ii surplus voting machines with the
curtain
if did your choices open the curtain and
they went
click and everything went all of a
sudden we have to print a ballot
so anyway i'm pretty good with computers
i made my choices i printed it out
all my choices are on there from
president on down ballot
and he said now you have to put it in
the scanner
and he turned over a sample ballot and
pointed at a weird triangle in the
corner
and smiled at me i didn't know what he
meant so i go over to the enter
and i'm wondering well a scanner works
face down when you scan because i have
one at home if i put it in face
down or face up so he's already across
the room
talking to another gentleman that's
about 20 years older than me
trying to tell him how to do it and i
said are these face up or face down and
he just nodded
he didn't say either way he just nodded
yes
so i put it in face off so i don't even
know if it scanned
the blank back side or the voting top
side
and anyway i overheard that conversation
not wittingly or
that i wanted to a man i'm 58
he was about 78 saying oh
they said to him that he understand and
he said yeah i think
but my memory is not too good and when i
walked out of there
i realized it's total
voter suppression my mother-in-law here
did not even get a cell phone until last
year has never sat at a computer
and keyed anything in her life has no
wi-fi or internet service at her house
neither does my mother she has a cell
phone but it's a flip type
and these are the people that went by
the thousands or millions to our polls
and had to go through this system
and i just wanted to point that out and
that's all i have
thank you thank you thank you
senator mastriano before we turn to our
our next panel i want to uh
note that senator cameron bartolotta has
joined us from southwestern pennsylvania
on zoom
and senator bob menge from the southeast
doug
thank you senator can we go over to the
final zoom panel
mr mayor we have more
okay
thank you scott
i think we have a surprise yes mr
chairman
okay i'm sorry is it my turn
uh just hold off one second just give me
a minute okay it's really hard to hear
you guys
guys
are we ready molly jenna
yes sir um okay mr chairman um
let them finish that testimony i'm
watching it's fantastic
but let them finish their test he wants
to finish the finish he wants to finish
okay all okay please uh can you hear me
on zoom if you can introduce yourself
and proceed
yeah can you hear me yes we got you loud
and clear
okay um my name is olivia jane winters
and i'm a professional organizer and a
business management consultant and i
live in philadelphia
um i actually was asked to be a minority
inspector
in um 3615. that's the award in the
division
um i was just purely doing this to help
my mom out she's a ward leader in a
different area of the city
um i'm actually not a i'm a registered
democrat
and i just wanted to help and make sure
it was a fair election
i don't i don't care who wins i care
that it's a fair election
um i showed up to the polls at 6 30 in
the morning
um immediately i was met with a hostile
attitude from all
of the people that i had to work with
that would be the majority inspector
the poll watcher the machine
operator and a committee man who was
electioneering in the polls he was
wearing
um he was wearing shirts and a hat
and a mask for who to vote for
um we are about like an hour and a half
in in the morning we have a long line of
people
we must have had i don't know 60 people
in line
in the building snaking around the
building
and um a woman came up and said i'd like
to
turn in my mail-in ballot so that i can
vote in the booth
and uh the girl who was clerking for me
said
well if you want to turn in your mail-in
ballot
we're going to need to have you fill out
this form and the majority inspector
is going to need to sign the form
the majority inspector had decided uh in
the middle of the morning
to go home and was not in the polling
place
for over 45 minutes to my understanding
you
as a minority as a um i'm sorry not the
majority inspector uh the judge of
elections my apologies
she had gone home and to my
understanding the judge of elections
is not to leave the polling place so she
was out of the building we needed her to
sign this form
the man who was electioneering and was a
poll watcher but also a committee man
confronted myself and the clerk and said
you don't know what you're talking about
anybody can sign the affidavit um why
don't you stop trying to cause problems
why don't you shut up
started getting in my face cursing at me
telling me that i needed to be quiet
that i didn't know what i was talking
about and i should just
learn to sit down and not say anything
and just let it happen
and my clerk and i said no we're not
going to let that happen that's
ridiculous
it says very clearly in our training and
on this sheet
that an affidavit needs to be signed by
the judge of elections if somebody's
going to turn in
a mail-in ballot before they can go vote
in the booth
we made her wait finally the judge of
elections came back
um not of course before he was
threatening me the uh majority inspector
threatened to
slap me in the face and uh he told me
that it was going to become a
quote-unquote racial issue
i'm not really sure why that would
become a racial issue it has nothing to
do with race that has everything to do
with
following procedure and making sure it's
an honest election
um i felt threatened i called my ward
leader
the ward leader then called the
commissioner for philadelphia
al schmidt al schmidt had me call
and report that to the d.a um
and then about an hour and a half after
that
uh the majority inspector told me that
she wanted to vote
because we had a lull in people coming
to the polls so it was pretty quiet
and i looked her name up so that she
could sign the book and it said that she
needed to remit her
mail-in ballot or vote provisionally
she said oh i threw that in the trash
and i said well then you have to vote
provisionally
and the machine operator and the same uh
committee man slash poll watcher
who was electioneering that i mentioned
before um
got up in my face again told me
that i didn't belong there that i needed
to shut up
started cursing expletives at me again
told me that they were going to allow
her to do that and i better be quiet
about it
and then they let her go into the polls
and vote
and she did not vote provisionally at
all she voted
and who knows maybe she voted twice not
to mention it wasn't until i had
actually called
our ward leader who had called the
commissioner
who had called the d.a that they then
sent
representatives down to discuss this
with me
and defend me i mean i had maybe
six men there because i was being
threatened in the polling place and
um his the committee man that i
mentioned earlier who is threatening me
then got his cousin involved who was
working the polls as a poll watcher and
was also wearing election hearing gear
she got up in my face demanded to see my
credentials then
uh refuse tried to refuse to give them
back to me told me that they were
illegitimate
minority inspector certificates um
they basically told me they were going
to call my council rep and he was going
to come down and make me leave
i just ridiculous threats um
i've been testified in a hearing for the
city of philadelphia for them
um on the same on election day regarding
uh this harassment and meanwhile i have
mentioned that um
until we had the deputy sheriff come
down and tell us
how to actually receive a mail-in ballot
and how to vote provisionally
we were not doing it correctly the judge
of elections was not
doing it correctly and i cannot stress
this enough my brother had the same
role as me as a minority inspector in a
different polling place
and he said they were not doing it
correctly either
i don't think that anybody actually
really knew
how to receive a mail-in ballot most of
the books that we had
to um to get your authorized signature
some would have a remit ballot um
little box that you could click and
others didn't have that at all
so if somebody came in and remitted a
ballot i'd almost have to like hand
write that in just to keep it as honest
as possible
there was no place for that so i don't
see really how they were keeping track
of that because you could easily
you could easily do both and i mean it
happened in front of me
my majority inspector definitely voted
and then went into the polls and voted
again
um and i unless you have questions i'm
not really sure
i think that's pretty much thank you
what happened thank you very much uh
senator mastrano
thank you if we can have our final
uh zoom like it was one or two more if
the next one can come forth
whenever you're ready
okay are you on
hello can you hear me hello okay
over to you we can hear you
am i on yes please begin you have the
floor
this is gloria lee snover i am
chairman of the northampton county
republican committee
northampton county is the democrat
counties where republicans win elections
i have been involved in a political
process in northampton county
for more than 25 years i've worked on
campaigns for township
supervisor to president of the united
states
this year was one of the most vast
complex elections
i have ever had to oversee as party
county chairman
the complexity was due to the new mail
and ballot system
and ever changing rules
the unmanned drop boxes in the general
election
that we did not have in the primary
also changing the fact that voters could
bring their ballot to the polls
and vote on the machine and many other
new procedures
there was mass confusion regarding the
mail and ballot system
i fielded scores of calls from
northampton county voters
and collected incident reports from
voters and poll watchers
regarding the november 3rd election the
typical calls i would feel
were i didn't ask for a mail-in ballot
why am i on the mail and ballot list i
did not get my ballot what should i do
it's been weeks how come my wife got her
ballot
and i didn't get one we applied on the
same
day how can i vote on the machines if i
applied for a ballot
is it safe to put my ballot in the mail
my ballot says it wasn't received and i
turned it into
the election office in person
my ballot says canceled what does that
mean
i voted in person and it still says not
counted
i've been on hold with the election
office 70 minutes
what do i do in turn because of these
questions
i had a number of phone calls and emails
correspondence with the election office
and the county solicitor
before election day trying to make sure
i was disseminating information
correctly
to the voters volunteers and the
campaign
one call turned heated when the
registrar threatened to turn me over to
the district attorney
for posting a picture of a voter valid
harvesting
a large bag of ballots at a northampton
county
dropbox it was my opinion the registrar
was more concerned we exposed it
rather than the fact that it was
happening
the most pertinent information i have to
offer this committee
was my conversations with the election
office
regarding curing the disqualified
naked ballot which they unlawfully
pre-campus before election day they
actually told me on the phone
early in october they felt them they
held them up to the light
they separated them out in different
boxes
reflecting back on these three weeks
in the experience the major concerns
regarding this election
are equal protection
were the democrats and republicans
treated the same
were they given the same information an
opportunity to vote
did they equally have an opportunity to
cure their disqualified ballot
not in my county
there was no ability to properly witness
the canvas of the mail-in ballot
or see the actual balance were there
signatures the solicitor told me there
is absolutely
no law that allows us to see the
counting or to see
the ballot to this day
we have no idea what
or whose ballots were counted
another one very strange there's a
pattern
of reactivated old voter rolls that kept
reoccurring on the sure system
the sure system is our pennsylvania
voter system
scores of people that had not voted
since the 1990s
more than 22 years ago were all
now reactivated and receiving
male imbalance people that didn't vote
for obama or hillary were all of a
sudden
receiving mail-in ballots setting up the
opportunity for fraud
on a massive scale that would go
undetected
because voters who never intended to
vote would not know
the sure system is not so sure
we also found in northampton county more
than 1500
votes where the mail-in ballot was
received
in the election office on a date before
it was
even mailed we have a problem
with this election thank you for
allowing me to share my election
experience and i plead with you
to remedy the mail and ballot process
thank you thank you for your testimony
and our last zoom are you
are you there can you hear me and if so
please begin
is there one more nope that's
that's it okay i guess a q a
let me begin now with uh questions from
our
representatives and senators i believe
probably about 30 minutes
up we have one additional witness
please all right i will introduce
to you now mr president you are
connected
[Applause]
great networks but uh i really
appreciate
being asked to speak and i'm in the oval
office right now
and it's very interesting to see what's
going on and
this was an election that we won easily
we wanted by a lot a big
energy official was on this morning
on a important show and said there's no
way
trump didn't win pennsylvania because
the energy industry was
all for him uh i saw you know with
with my eyes what happened and he told
me horror stories
absolute horror stories so this was a
very sad to say it
this election was rigged and we can't
let that happen
we can't let it happen for our country
and this
election has to be turned around because
we won pennsylvania by a lot and we won
all of these swing states by a lot
anybody watching television the night of
the election was saying
wow i was called by the biggest
political people congratulations sir on
a big win
and all of a sudden ballots were dumped
all over the place and a lot of
horrible things happened and everybody
in that room i want to thank all of the
people that signed affidavits and all of
the speakers
you fantastic people your great patriots
i want to thank
the senators for being there and it's so
important
day before thanksgiving it really
represents somebody between
the voter suppression and all of the
horrible things that happened to poll
watchers
we have poll watcher affidavits piled up
to the ceiling
they're all over they were treated
horribly all over this
uh in all all of these swing states i
mean virtually all of the swing states
and many other things were happening
that were horrible
just horrible but the poll watchers
weren't allowed to watch
they were in many cases whisked out of
the room not only into pens that were
20 30 40 60 100 feet away
where you couldn't even see they were
using binoculars people are reporting
that they had to use binoculars and that
didn't work
if you were a republican poll watcher
you were treated like a dog
and the democrats had no problem but
they were rough
they were they were literally pushed out
and it was rough tactics this is what
what happened here this is not
the united states of america what
happened and i think everybody knows
that that's why you're
there and that's why you're so vehement
about it
we have many many cases many many
cases of people walking in a a woman
an elderly woman walks in looking
forward to
voting november 3rd and says oh good
where would i
go about voting i'm sorry you've already
voted your ballot is in
i said no i didn't vote i didn't vote no
your ballot is in you've already voted
in all cases for biden by the way she
said no no i want to vote
nope your ballot is in and then they
give her a provisional ballot to sign
which goes nowhere
it's a disgrace that this is happening
to our country
we won this election by a lot we got 74
million votes
and if you would have said 74 million
votes the day before the election
every single professional in the
business would have said there's no way
of beating that we got 11 million votes
more
than we had four years before in 2016.
and we got many votes more than ronald
reagan had when he won 49 states
and nobody would have said we even had a
chance of losing
and all you had to do was take a look at
the numbers at 10 o'clock in the evening
when everybody thought the election was
virtually over then
very weird things happen but they're not
weird to professionals and they're not
weird to dominion
and other people that operate machines
and they're not weird
to the people that handle the ballots
where they were flooding the market
people were getting two and three and
four ballots in their home
people that were dead were signing up
for ballots not only were they
coming in and putting in a ballot
but dead people were requesting ballots
and they were dead for years and they
were requesting ballot
ballots and the whole world is watching
us the whole world is watching the
united states of america
and we can't let them get away with it
and we have judges that are
afraid to make a decision we have judges
that don't want to do the same thing
a very good lawyer said well sir i mean
that's a big statement for
a judge to overthrow an election i said
really
if he got hundreds of thousands of votes
more than he was entitled to get through
all of the things that i'm listening to
right now
and you're just covering a few of them
we have we have
hundreds and hundreds of affidavits
of stories that are even worse than the
stories i'm hearing
why wouldn't they overturn an election
certainly overturn it in your state
because we have other states that are
just as bad
if you look at michigan with detroit you
look at the things that happened in
detroit
where you have a voter but you have more
votes
than you have voters you take a look at
detroit michigan
you have more votes and you have voters
and then you have two people
that don't want to certify they don't
want to certify and they're harassed
violently and they turned off the
cameras during the harassment
for two hours and then they said wow
and they were afraid and they voted and
then they went back to sign and they
couldn't do it because they said we
can't do it because this is corrupt
this is horrible what's taking place
think of it more votes than you have
voters
but that was the least of it they have
things that were
as bad as that and this is going on all
over
all over we're doing very well in a lot
of states a lot of good things are
happening in georgia we're getting
little help from
government but a lot of good things are
happening in georgia wisconsin
and michigan they're seeing what
happened in detroit
and we sure are looking at what's
happening in
pennsylvania and philadelphia what
happened in philadelphia they keep the
poll watchers
not only in pens but they keep them out
of the building
and the only reason they got back into
the building was they got a court order
and then the definition of back into the
building was very far away where they
couldn't see anything
and they talked about closed circuit
television except you couldn't see it
because the picture was so unclear you
didn't even know what they were doing
they could have been playing a baseball
game so it's a very sad thing for our
country to have this
and they have to turn over the results
it would be easy for me to say
oh let's worry about four years from now
now
this election was lost by the democrats
they cheated it was a fraudulent
election they flooded the market
[Applause]
and i just want to thank everybody for
being there
you're doing a tremendous service a very
important moment
in the history of our country and you're
doing a tremendous service to our
country
and don't worry about bravery because
the people that talk the most they're
not the ones you have to worry about and
these are all talkers they intimidate
but these are not people that you can
ultimately have to they push you around
they pushed our workers out our poll
watchers were pushed out of the building
okay some got back in they were put in
the bands
but these are not people don't be
intimidated by these people
but they're bad people they're horrible
people
and they're people that don't love our
country so we don't have to worry about
four years right now
we have to worry what happened on
november 3rd and previous to november
3rd
and by the way after november 3rd when
people put votes in
and they put them in illegally they put
them in
after the polls closed and one of our
great supreme court justices
made mention of that and i can't imagine
that any justice or
anybody looking at it could be thrilled
when they vote after the election
is over so i want to thank everybody
very much for being there i want to
thank
the state senate respected people
tremendous people
and you're doing a tremendous service
for our country and if something was
done wrong
if this election was won fraudulently
and that's what happened it was a fraud
and we're talking about
very importantly many more ballots many
more votes
than the number we need in other words
if we needed 50
000 votes we're not talking about we
found nine
dead people that voted of course there
were many more than that
many numbers that nobody even believes
now we're talking about numbers that are
far in excess of the fifty thousand far
in excess of another
state where we lost by ten thousand and
they went
absolutely wild because we got far more
votes than they thought possible
and they've just stepped in the gas and
they got caught
just like i got caught spying on my
campaign they got caught
exactly they got caught doing this so
i really appreciate it and the country
appreciates it
and we have to turn the election over
because
there's no doubt we have all the
evidence we have all the affidavits we
have everything
all we need is to have some judge listen
to it properly
without having a political opinion or
having
another kind of a problem because we
have everything and by the way the
evidence is pouring in now as we speak
and i want to thank rudy giuliani for
having the courage
to do this
[Applause]
is the greatest mayor in the history of
new york and there's a reason
he's got great courage and he doesn't
care he wants to do what's right
and i told him the other day rudy you
were the greatest mayor in the history
of new york and you see what happened to
new york without rudy
you were the greatest mayor but this is
more important what you're doing now is
far
more important than being a great mayor
of the city of new york and being its
greatest mayor by far by the way by far
this is going to be your crowning
achievement
because you're saving our country thank
you all very much
thank you
i think what you've just heard
guarantees that a hundred years from now
that this is the most important public
hearing
ever held by the senate committee
[Applause]
[Music]
we turn now for questions
representative representative ryan
first of all thank you very much uh
mayor for being here for all the
testifiers you know 16 years ago
this week i was called out of retirement
and recalled active duty to go to iraq
to do the elections in iraq
in january 30 2005.
that was an extraordinarily secure
election
as a former commanding officer of a
civil affairs group
and psychological operations command i
know how to do elections
and what happened in pennsylvania from a
process control perspective
was absolutely a travesty
what i am concerned about is the remedy
how do we go from here we we see that
there's a perspective
from our council that a 1937 law
provided the ability to appoint the
electors to
the secretary of state and i'm curious
as to whether or not
sir you believe a special prosecutor
should be appointed at the federal level
to look at all these irregularities or
whether or not there is still actions
that can be done at the state level
to ensure that the goal of what we're
attempting to do
is to ensure as we did for the people in
iraq and as i did with the people in
haiti
to ensure that the results are fair
accurate
transparent and a representation of the
will of the people of the united states
my suggestion would be and of course
there are
several different remedies that you
could have one one
would be to declare that the votes
that were not inspected properly
he declared mel and void in that county
and deducted from the vote total
it's essentially what they do in wiscon
wisconsin has the strictest
absentee law in the country they require
an application
for every ballot and when they finish
they only count the number of absentee
ballots that have an application
they deduct from the total from that
county whatever are missing
so if you have five thousand absentee
ballots
but only four thousand applications you
deduct one thousand votes
and the reason they do that is to deter
people from doing that in the future
look at it this way
if you didn't deduct
the 678 000 or whatever it is votes
that were not counted there's no penalty
for it
what stops them from doing it again next
time
and it's this is a question of not
voters acting improperly
it's a question of the inferior offices
of this state because they're inferior
to the legislature in this regard
acted improperly they conducted a
completely sham election
they're the ones who have to be penal
it's a little like the exclusionary rule
in criminal law they've got to be taught
you can't do that
the other thing you could do is you
could demand
to see all of the
all of the envelopes that were cast
aside
like i will virtually guarantee
you're going to see a couple of hundred
thousand envelopes that have
no names partial names the same name
you could ask to see the ballots you're
probably going to see
ballots that are official and ballots
that are unofficial
you have two major gaps you have the 672
770 votes that were not
inspected by anyone secretly put into
the ballot box
and then you have this gap that i don't
understand between
the mail-in ballots you sent out 1.8
million
and the number you counted 2.5 million
that's totally impossible to explain
other than what some of the witnesses
were suggesting
that they were that they were basically
uh
stuffing the ballot box i believe what
happened is they never expected to be
behind by seven or eight hundred
thousand votes on election night
they expected to be behind by a couple
hundred thousand in philadelphia to
steal a couple hundred thousand votes
they do it every year that's not gonna
be tough now you had a real big problem
so you had to create mail-in ballots you
had to stretch it out for a while
we didn't go into detail on the dominion
system
but we have two other experts who can
show you how they injected votes
into the dominion system and also so i
think i would settle settle
this election but i would definitely
appoint a special prosecutor
to prosecute the people who conducted
this election you might even ask just a
general question
how could the governor and the elections
commissioner
how could they have selected a company
that counts our votes outside the united
states
amen i didn't know that
thank you thank you
representative mall questions for any of
our panelists
this is like our lightning round here to
conclude
uh thank you uh mr chairman um
i think what i'm going to do is make
more of a statement to
throw out a timeline because to to try
and reiterate what everyone else has
already done
just be a couple years ago
our supreme court in pennsylvania
very illegally redrew congressional maps
it's very clear in our constitution that
is a legislative
act um fast forward
a couple of months ago our supreme court
rewrote our election law
again that is needs to be done in
statute
it is a legislative act
when it came to the mail-in ballotings
uh
that that house bill i want to say 77
act 77 um i was
really kind of taken aback by
how eager the governor was to sign that
bill normally
bills can sit in his desk eight and
almost 10 days before he signs them or
lets them
become law on their own or vetoes them
right away and that when he signed
almost instantaneously and i just kind
of wondered
so after i saw what happened in the
primary
i wrote house bill 2626
and this is where it kind of locks it in
for me mr mayor
and panelist in house bill 2626
i saw where there could possibly be
stuffing the boxes so i said simply
let's put a barcode
on the bottom of every mail out ballot
so that the machine has to read a
barcode
that was accepted by the election's
office
before that ballot goes out they zap it
when it comes back if that barcode
doesn't match one of the barcodes that
they sent out
it gets kicked out the governor
immediately as soon as we ran that bill
out of committee said
that hits my desk it's an automatic veto
not not everybody knows that but that
came to us
we had to literally strip that out of
the bill and i will be reintroducing a
bill to barcode any ballot that gets
mailed out
when we get back trust me
[Applause]
then we have the drop boxes three days
extra to vote the ignoring the
signatures and ignoring the postmarks
and i have to come to the conclusion
that you did also
if it looks like corruption smells like
corruption
it's corruption and we've got to get to
the bottom of it
thank you for being here thank you for
your testimony
appreciate it very much thank you mr
chairman thank you senator regan
thank you mr mayor thank you so much for
being here thank you to all our
testifiers today it's been very
informative um my question uh mr mayor
you touched upon it briefly but i want
to just
if you could delve it a little bit more
into it attorney general barr
shortly after the election authorized
the u.s attorneys across the country to
investigate
allegations of of voter fraud i wonder
if you could tell us about the criminal
investigations that are going on maybe
specifically in pennsylvania by our u.s
attorneys maybe our fbi
uh and tell us how that is going and
is there any evidence that's been
presented to you or are you
made privy to any of this information
i'm sorry senator
i wouldn't be made privy to that
criminal investigations
and in my experience criminal
investigations you know would take too
long
to help you in your most immediate
decision criminal investigations could
help you in your long-term decision
as to how to reform so this never
happens again
which i think uh you you all
will want to do for example not ever
hiring again
a company that counts votes in frankfurt
germany
that's owned by two venezuelans who are
very close to yugosh
chavez and maduro that's extraordinary
and unfortunately we don't have the time
to really analyze the votes although if
you want to go into greater detail we
have other forensic experts that can
show you
votes that were specifically put into
the machine
because these machines have a back door
that allows you to do that
so i would say the criminal proceedings
are going to take six months to a year
what what you have before you that you
can verify is
you have before your very very clear
evidence it's not small it's not as if
these are a couple little mistakes
that happen and ever i hear people say
oh every election has a couple of little
mistakes
not 682 000 ballots
that nobody got to inspect that from
time immemorial
we we've never had trouble in america
with absentee ballots i've been an
absentee ballot contest
in new york and they can you know they
can be pretty
vicious and the language is worse than
that poor lady
experience but we would never think of
having one without the republican there
and the democrat there
even we would never think of it here
did it 700 000 times
that's an insult to to the legislature
because you didn't provide for that
and you've got this gap of 700 000
unexplained
mail-in ballots that come out of nowhere
so i think you have more than enough to
say
that this election the numbers don't add
up
it's easy to figure out what the right
numbers are by excluding the
illegal votes and count the honest votes
and the winner of the election changes
thank you very much sir
thank you senator senator mario scavello
i'm just going to make a couple of
comments first i want to thank everybody
for coming out here today
we need your support your continued
support throughout this whole process
because we're going to also get the
other side that don't want us to do
anything at all
and we definitely need to do something
we need to correct this problem
um my northampton
county chairperson lee snowa did an
excellent job
explaining what was going on in
northampton county
one of the biggest things that bothered
me more than anything else was people
that
went back went to vote and
they were told they already voted that
happened
i must have heard it from 50 people
between in my district
so you know they they they made them
assign a provisional and i called up and
i said
i'm you better make sure that those
provisionals are counted and
some of the other things that were
happening that that you know most of the
stuff that you said out there it
happened in every county
but um when you didn't
want to vote with your absentee and you
went in
you're supposed to get a ballot not a
provisional
and there were people out there that got
provisionals
but uh just a little uh information for
all of you
the new machines this new process
we didn't vote for it that was something
that was pushed by the governor
he mandated that they all of the
counties had to go and change their
system
because he wanted some type of um
uh what we don't have is a form to see
what they
who voted or what what who who voted
they want a certificate or something a
slip
to see how you voted who voted and
it's obvious that this system has not
worked
and the people of pennsylvania are not
happy about it
thank you thank you
madam majority leader elect thank you
first of all i just want to say what
they did in philadelphia
when they closed us out and made us go
to court to do what we should have
legally been able to do is a
travesty to what what we in pennsylvania
need to have confidence in our elections
that should never happen again and we
should probably tighten our law so that
it can't
secondly i'm extremely bothered by the
um
the the absentee ballot and the mail-in
ballot request
number being almost 700 000 off
from what we received uh
and so we just did try to get on the
department of state and they did take
down
their dashboard so we can't even check
it so if you have any of that
information
any pictures or any you know website
downloads we would really appreciate
having those
because they took them down so i don't
know everything they do looks like
they're trying to hide something and
it really really continues to erode
any kind of confidence in our process
senator what i would suggest is they
decided that morning or maybe a couple
of days before to exclude you
because they knew what they were going
to do it wasn't done it wasn't an
accidental
sort of whim to exclude all republicans
it's unheard of to exclude all
republicans
they excluded you because of what you
would see
you would see ballots that weren't
properly filled out you would see
ballots that were filled out at the last
minute
you would see them start to get reports
of how far behind they were
because they were connecting to dominion
and smartmatic
and they were telling them how far
behind they were and you would have
caught them
right in the middle of the fraud and why
create this big problem for yourself
of excluding republicans in six states
hundreds and maybe thousands of them if
you're not doing something wrong
if you're doing something as the senator
said it's kosher
come on look who cares this this big
thing wasn't done
because they were conducting an honest
vote it's kind of crazy to think that
this was done because they knew this is
the only way they could steal this
election
and when he was ahead by those numbers
on uh tuesday night wednesday morning
they panicked
i'll also tell you there's an accurate
witness who can testify
that this pattern fits the pattern that
smartmatic
used in two elections that they stole
south america
when the election was getting too far
away they called a halt
in the voting camp well there was a halt
called in six places including in
pennsylvania
in one place they may believe there was
an overflowed
water tank it happened to be one little
toilet bowl
they took a two-hour halt and in
michigan
they brought in a hundred thousand
ballots through the back door
and counted them with nobody observing
them except three people who happen to
be remaining behind
that that's evidence that's also in
affidavits
and could be presented to the michigan
legislature those people are willing to
testify
and just one other thing these people
are very brave people
a lot of people aren't testifying
they're backed up they're backed up by
50 more who are willing to testify
obviously we can't present all of them i
want you to know that all of them
are backed up by numerous witnesses who
say the same thing
but there are probably another 50 who
were not willing to testify
including probably what would have been
one of our best witnesses because he's
been threatened with the loss of his job
and his children being thrown out of
their private school
thank you very much mr mayor thank you
thank you senator let's try our zoom
capabilities here uh senator michelle
brooks
calling in from northwestern
pennsylvania
thank you senator argel i did want to
make
a comment first i joined my colleagues
in being concerned about the arbitrary
supreme court decisions and their
decision
to decide to be legislators
and all pennsylvanians need to be
concerned about this
uh you know it's not only the election
or redrawing maps what's going to be
next that impacts our state
and so not only do we need to be looking
at what happened with this election
we need to be looking at how we
can stop the pennsylvania supreme court
from wanting to legislate when that's
not what they're supposed to be doing
and it's very disconcerting
the decisions they made contrary to
state
law in regards to this election
my question is if you could talk about
the drop-off boxes again something the
pennsylvania supreme court
allowed talk about
the security around them i know in my
area i did not
have a significant amount of drop boxes
but can you talk about
what type of security or parameter
parameters
of safety were around these drop-off
boxes
and also how many ballots were collected
in these drop boxes thank you
that that of course the subject of
another lawsuit was brought the other
day
i only know it generally the drop-off
boxes were
provided speaking very broadly
in the democrat part of the states not
in the republican par
parts of the state they were many many
many very closely
you